elles sont de véritables pointures dans
leur discipline les gymnastes de
l'équipe de france reprennent leur
entraînement de préparation olympique
melanie l'aurait tallinn
alizée morgan claire et célia elles sont
toutes présentes pour une reprise
intensive sous le soleil très bien
devenir un archonte fait chaud ça change
dans son vin en métropole et bat pour
les entraînements à son tour prendre
pour les échéances à venir et être prête
pour les grandes compétitions et les
tests surtout avant des championnes qui
impressionne ce jour là les petites
gymnastes regarde les grandes faire elle
souhaite pour la plupart atteindre ce
niveau pour un jour se présenter dans
les compétitions nationales et
internationales
c'est impressionnant parce que parce
qu'elles font plein de choses que moi
j'aimerais bien faire plus tard comme
les fip flessel toi avant est-ce que tu
rey et m comme elle plus tard
oui pourquoi mais parce que pour passer
à la télé est championne de gym avoir
des trophées rencontrer des
une opportunité pour les licenciés des
clubs martiniquais y assister à un
entraînement de haut niveau n'est pas
chose courante et ne peut être que
ludique et pédagogique
j'espère qu'au prochain entraînement
elles sont encore plus déterminé pour
obtenir leurs éléments à pour progresser
elle voit la détermination de chacun
chacune des filles elle voit que tous
les éléments qu'on leur demande
d'apprendre ça ne vient pas d'un
claquement de doigts et puis a dû
énormément de travail derrière celle qui
attire tous les regards et qui épate le
public du jour on ne la présente plus
c'est mélanie de jesús dos santos à 19
ans elle est la française la plus titrée
aux championnats d'europe de gymnastique
artistique elle accumulé sept titres de
championne de france et est aujourd'hui
fière d'être en modèle jeu surtout
montré en faisant ma gym que je prends
plaisir et que c'est pas une contrainte
donc à chaque fois qu'ils me font coucou
majeur fait coucou et puis j'essaye de
prendre le temps de discuter avec
l'équipe de france de gymnastique
artistique féminine s'entraînera au
stade louis achille jusqu'au 12 janvier